what you're seeing here is scp-682 after  undergoing a major mutation as a result  of testing a new method of termination  which is currently redacted to  unauthorized personnel only know is that  it shattered the confines of its acid  bath containment chamber which is now  undergoing maintenance it has developed  for large appendages that can be used  for feeding causing tremendous harm to  any one nerve but anything within its  reach in addition its Corsa was also  expanded to accommodate the potential  mass it can ingest before cameras  started recording it consumed almost 6  d-class in a matter of minutes we can  predict that 682 will eventually revert  back to its previous form as with all of  its other mutations all we can do at  this point is study its behavior and  hope it doesn't breach containment lost  in this state updates to follow  [Music]  Oh  [Music]